[Music]
as Plato has Socrates sketch out this
this ideal city this ideal human
community that responds to the kinds of
needs and wants and desires that that
are part of the human condition we find
find that Plato proposes a class system
and it's not a class system in the sense
that we're used to thinking about
because we tend to think in terms of
income or social classes there's a
little bit of that here except that
interestingly enough the people who are
at the top don't make any money they uh
are deprived they're not allowed to
enjoy the fruits of uh of rule or or
dominance at the top we have the
Guardians and he clarifies and says look
we really need to say that that these
are the true Guardians these are the
ones who really deserve the name the
rulers the ones who take care of the
City by arranging everything by
producing good laws by doing the
Planning by all the sorts of things that
go into making a city run and then there
are the auxiliary Guardians the the ones
who he called Guardians at the start in
book two and he's going to change that
little a little bit later these are the
soldiers the police we could think of
other professions where courage and
resisting danger for the benefit of the
community is required like say
firefighters
um you could probably come up with a lot
of other things and then there's the
class of just everybody else and Plato
is willing to lump in there even people
like the priests or the the skilled
Craftsmen they just have their jobs that
they do and so long as they stick to
their jobs everything's fine as a matter
of fact they can even own property they
can become rich they can chill out and
and hang you know get get their work
done these guys are the ones who
actually have the the the jobs that are
like salary jobs where you're never
really off the
clock so the question is then how do we
make sure that these people that these
social roles that these classes are
actually doing what they need to do so
that the city can run
well and we can we can do a couple
different things we can look for say
aptitude
right and that's what I have down here
Plato says you know we do need to look
for people who are are spirited who have
that sense of you know I'm going to get
engaged but are also gentle they're
they're not you know just totally out of
control we don't want any Berserkers as
the soldiers in this city um um and then
you know when it comes to the rulers we
want people who are actually curious who
are intelligent and so you know he talks
about this a little bit the question we
want to ask ourselves is is it going to
be enough to find the right Talent or do
we have to develop that Talent further
but let's look first at his discussion
so this is the end of uh our our reading
of book two he says we need these people
to be full of spirit full of thumos full
of of of as they say spit and vinegar I
know they there's another word that they
use for that but I I'm going to keep it
clean here so he says how are we going
to find a gentle nature who also has a
great spirit it seems like they're
contradictions people who are laidback
Gentle Spirit they don't tend to be the
go-getters they don't tend to be the
ambitious ones the ones who are getting
involved and making a difference these
seem to be at antipodes with each other
and so he says
well let's think again about dogs many
animals furnish examples of these these
Natures that are gifted with opposite
qualities our friend the dog is a good
one you know that well-bred dogs are
perfectly gentle to their familiars and
acquaintances and the reverse to
strangers so remember we wanted the
auxiliaries to be the kind of people who
would fight in war against the the enemy
or if they're police they're going to
resist the criminal within but we want
them to be good we want them to be kind
we want them to be gentle with the
civilians the citizens of the city so he
says um there's nothing impossible or
out of the order of nature in finding a
guardian who has a similar combination
of
qualities would would not he who's
fitted to be a guardian besides the
spirited nature need to have the
qualities of a philosopher he says and
here he's going to actually start
talking more about the higher
Guardians so he says and he's joking
around here he says the trait that I'm
looking for is actually found in a dog
um why because the dog is going by
making everything depend on knowledge
when a dog when he sees a stranger is
angry uh but when he sees an
acquaintance he welcomes him why is this
well because it depends on knowledge he
knows the the the person that he likes
he doesn't know the stranger and so he
says surely this Instinct of the dog is
very Charming your dog is a true
philosopher now Plato doesn't believe
that for a minute dogs are not
philosophers but he's he's making a
metaphor here and then he says he uses
this criteria of knowing and not knowing
and then he goes and he makes an
inference and must not an animal be a
lover of learning that's what it means
to be curious that's also part of what
goes into intelligence to be a lover of
learning that's what for Plato fits a
person to have authority to have power
to have uh a position to be put in
charge because if you put other people
in charge who just want power for its
own sake or just want it for the money
ah things don't go so good but if you
put somebody in power who actually wants
to figure out what the good thing is
you're a lot better off you're a lot
more likely for them to make good
decisions so he's talking about this
person here philosopher is somebody who
loves learning who loves wisdom that's
what philosophy is so he says may we not
say confidentally confidently of man
also that he who is likely to be gentle
to his friends and acquaintances must by
Nature be a lover of wisdom and
knowledge so he's saying there's some
sort of connection between these two
now at the end of that he's saying
that's great we we found our our
candidates how are we going to educate
them but why does he have to think about
education isn't it enough just to go
with this you know aptitude or
disposition these people are suited to
rule these people are Suited to do the
Fighting No it takes training human
beings unlike most other animals aren't
just a matter of instinct if these are
to some degree instinctual or
dispositional something that they're
they're born with that's not enough
those things have to be developed
further and that's what he's going to
talk about in book three and in many of
the other
books in this uh dialogue so
it may actually erase more uh but let's
stick with this for the time
being what do we need to to say about
these these people he he talks about
lying right um Plato is is very
interested in truth and lying and what
the guardians or the rulers are going to
to say about that why is he so concerned
with that because he thinks that the the
culture
the predominant culture of ancient
Greece contains um some
truth and far too many
lies and if you're trying to educate
somebody you need to actually teach them
the truth of things if you want somebody
to understand human nature their own
nature what's good for them you can't
bring them up on a bunch of Lies so he
says the rulers are going to have to
punish anybody who is telling lies he
says the rulers can lie for the common
good only for the common good and we'll
talk about the idea of the noble lie in
a bit but nobody else should meddle with
anything of this kind for a private man
to lie to them in return is to be deemed
a more heinous fault than for the
patient or the pupil of a gymnasium not
to speak the truth about his own bodily
illnesses to The Physician or the
trainer or for a sailor not to tell his
captain what's happening about the ship
if the ruler catches anybody beside him
lying in the state then he'll punish
them why because it's destructive of the
society then he goes on to talk about
some other dispositions what else do we
need so we need people to
be
truthful we need people also he
says to be temperate what does it mean
to be temperate you might think that
that means that you know it's it's warm
outside and not too cold not too hot
Temperance means moderation and
self-control so you don't want the
Warriors to be a bunch of drunks or a
bunch of druggies you know constantly
getting in trouble because they're
they're not going to be very good at
their jobs let alone if the rulers are
are in that case so he says um
Temperance what does that consist in he
says are not the chief elements of that
obedience to commanders being able to
control oneself and self-control and
sensual Pleasures so we're going to
prove language like that of diam and
Homer friends sit still and obey my word
and the Greeks marched breathing prowess
um you know and all sorts of things but
what about these sorts of things oh
heavy with wine who C who has the eyes
of a dog and the Heart of a stag are we
going to allow that sort of thing to be
said and to be approved of to our young
Guardians no why because that's going to
be sort of teaching them in Temperance
and Plato is very attentive to the
effects that artistic representations
you know for us that would not just be
the poets that would be Netflix and Hulu
and all these these you know shows that
we watch and you YouTube and our music
and we could keep on adding in all these
cultural products our blogging right
these create the fabric not only of a
society and they're not just they're not
just purveying information they're
purveying attitudes they are
inculcating attitudes about what's right
and what's wrong what's what's to be
approved and what's to be criticized so
if we want people to be temperate we
need to actually put examples before
them we need to to laad Temperance so he
says
um we you know we want to get over some
of these he's got some some good
examples the saddest of Fates is to die
and meet Destiny from from Hunger says
that's not that's not the sort of thing
we want our our Guardians listening to
um what about money do we want them to
be
greedy uh we must not sing to them of
gifts persuading gods and persuading
Reverend Kings we want them to be um
imitators of something else now he
brings up this term
imitation and that's part of what's
going on in art and going going on in
culture this imitation process that's
how we become truthful that's how we
become temperate says let me ask you
whether our Guardians ought to be
imitators um and he says can can our
Guardians imitate other functions can
imitate other people can they live their
ways of life even if just partly can
they be like kids who put on a costume
or play act or engage in you know Cops
and Robbers for a while says no they
can't really do that if they want to be
good at their job if they want to
fulfill their role they need to stick to
that so he says no man can imitate many
things as well as he would imitate a
single one so if there's going to be
anything they should imitate the the
auxiliaries ought to imitate the heroism
of other auxiliaries
the Guardians ought to imitate the
wisdom of other
Guardians he gives examples about
tragedy and comedy he says um the same
people can't do the same the same things
so if we adhere to our original notion
and bear in mind that our Guardians are
to dedicate themselves totally to the
maintenance of freedom in the state
making this their craft and engaging in
no work which is not be on their end
they ought not to practice or imitate
anything else if they imitate at all
they should imitate from youth upward
only those characters which are suitable
to their
profession the temperate and then he
also brings up
the
courageous the holy the free and the
like but they should not imitate those
who are base those who are are coarse
those who
are cowardly because then they're going
to start to take on that kind of
character so he says um how are we going
to be able to figure this out though
what what are these things here Plato is
going to bring up a very important point
that leads to what we call the it's not
called here in this this text but it's
going to be called this in other places
the doctrine of the
forms
and the basic idea behind the doctrine
of the forms is that
um there we
go the things that we see the visible
things the things that we encounter in
our our
experiential uh life are many they're
multiple so if we're thinking for
example about C courageous people let's
just take
that so we have a courageous man right
and we have a courageous
woman and now we have another courageous
woman and we can keep on going on and on
and
on how do we write recognize all these
as
courageous is courage just a name that
we apply to them then it starts to seem
like it's totally
arbitrary there must be some quality
they actually have in common for PL that
quality is the courage that they possess
and none of their courage is
perfect all of their coures refer to the
ideal form
of Courage which would be totally
courageous and we're able to recognize
these as courageous people as having
courage we're able to to make sense out
of what they have because there is this
pattern as he calls it this form this
idea in in Greek idea that we're able to
use that we have some dim recollection
of that we can recognize so he says
let's think about how this works just as
in learning to read we were satisfied
when we knew the letters of the alphabet
in all their sizes and
combinations
um we were able to make them out um as
we recognize the reflection of the the
letters in the water or in a mirror or
when we only when we know the letters
themselves the same art and study giving
us the knowledge of both there's a key
idea there's some sort of knowledge
that helps us make this
identification we want our Guardians he
says neither we nor our Guardians whom
we educate can ever become as he says
Musical that is versed in in uh you know
education until we and they know the
essential forms and all their
combinations and can recognize them in
the images see for for
Plato not only are painted images or you
know literary images or an actor up on
stage not not only are they
imitations of some some truer
reality even the courage that we feel
that we possess that we act on that we
exemplify is just an image an imitation
of the true reality of courage in itself
and we want to be able to understand
what that is without a a reference to
that we're in a certain way blind we're
not able to make sense of it and so
we're going to make mistakes when it
comes to say courage so he
says um this is what education should
provide us with it's going to harmonize
us with these these ideal realities he
says now what can take that knowledge
away from
us what can get in the way
Pleasure and
Pain
intemperance
wanness certain kinds of Love Can can
pull us away from that so we want to be
careful with the sort of affects or
emotions or desires uh or feelings that
that come
up so he goes on and he says um we need
to train train these people both in body
and mind that's why he talks about music
and Gymnastic we tend to think of
gymnastics as a very specialized kind of
exercise he means bodily exercise in
general and music he means mental
exercise and training education in
general so he says um we need these
Guardians to develop this ability to see
the ideal in the material they also have
to undergo training rigorous training um
of the body they have to avoid
intoxication he says um they have to
learn how to eat you know food that's
fairly simple um now why he
says neither of these two Arts music and
Gymnastic is really designed one for the
training of the soul the other for the
training of the body they're really both
to train the soul to train the mind to
train the person
ity he says as a matter of fact if you
devote yourself just to the body you're
actually not going to come out very well
it produces a temper of hardness and
ferocity he says we don't want that we
want our Guardians to to be in a kind of
Harmony and so remember we began with
sort of their Raw Talent their raw um
aptitudes and now we're seeing these
aptitudes develop in The Crucible of an
education which is partly an education
towards things saying look these are the
examples you should be imitating here's
the knowledge that you should be
acquiring here's the discipline that you
have to undergo it's also an education
away from other things don't pay
attention to you know that music over
there to those TV shows don't pay
attention to the heroes that aren't
really Heroes Plato wouldn't have him
wouldn't have people watching Breaking
Bad for example right he'd have them
watching other things instead
so he goes on and he says
um here we go
um music and gymnastics or body and mind
need to be
harmonized let's put this up here there
we
go
these are all ultimately for the soul or
the
mind and there has to be a proper
proportion
between these
two so he says
um here we
go why do we want to avoid getting into
disproportion he says our Guardians need
to have certain
qualities this by itself will promote a
kind of hardness ferocity it'll promote
the spirited side of things it'll
promote what we call thumos and what
we're going to talk about a little bit
more if all we do is focus on this then
the he says the mere athlete becomes too
much of a Savage on the other hand the
person who's only playing paying
attention to music or we'll call it
culture um there's a tendency to become
sort of weak to become LAX to become too
uh gentle to to not really have the kind
of rigor that's needed so what we want
is something in between we want this
balance so they they have to be in
harmony the harmonious soul is both
temperate and courageous we want that in
our
Guardians there's a last point that we
have to talk about here with respect to
the education of these these two
important
classes and Plato is going to talk about
the need to observe them throughout
their life as children in order to test
them to make sure that the the Guardians
who we saw have a sort of
aptitude and are receiving an
education
education um and a sort of
discipline we need to see whether all of
this leads to the
right
choices and so how do you tell that well
the only way to actually do that is to
put people to the test so he says um let
us note among the Guardians who in their
whole life show the greatest eagerness
to do what is good for their country the
greatest repugnance to do what is
against their interests these are the
people we want let's watch them to see
whether they preserve preserve their
resolution and never under the influence
of either force or enchantment forget or
cast off their sense of Duty to the
state how cast off Glen says I'll
explain it to you here's the way a
resolution can go out of a person's mind
it can go out of their mind willingly or
unwillingly willingly when we see that
it's better to do this and and we
resolve to do do this we say yeah but
that's good over there unwillingly when
it's um leading us to something evil to
something that's false so he says do you
not see that men are unwillingly
deprived of good and willingly of evil
is not not to have lost the truth and
evil and to possess the truth of good
and you would agree that to conceive
things as they are is to possess the
truth so how do we actually what is he
talking about there how do we actually
fall into error how do we make mistakes
how do we make the wrong choices instead
of the right choices he says well this
deprivation of the truth is either
caused by theft or force or enchantment
and so s says I understand is a little
hard to get I mean that some men are
changed by
persuasion some
forget argument steals away the hearts
of one class and time the other and this
I call theft something is stealing away
the truth making the right choices is
dependent on preserving the truth those
again who are forced are those who the
violence of some pain or grief compels
to change their opinion I tell you
unless you recant I'm going to punish
you and you find some way to change your
mind
and then he says you would also
acknowledge that the enchanted are those
who change their minds under the softer
influence of pleasure or the Sterner
influence of
fear so who do we want we want the
people who are not going to be affected
by pain pleasure
desire fear other people's
pressure culture we want people who are
going to stick with the truth and cleave
to that good
so that they can make the right choices
throughout the course of their life and
we have to observe them to see who is
actually able to do this because we
can't predict just on the basis of
aptitude education and discipline that
everybody is going to in fact succeed